[Music]
as we take a tour of the Redwood
National Park in Northern California we
are bound to be awestruck by a mere
glance of the giant redwood trees the
height of over 380 feet makes them the
world's tallest trees but ever wondered
how they maintained the uniformity how
is it that a redwood tree grows to an
unimaginable height but still has the
same wood and similar leaves throughout
let me give you another example take the
case of human beings if we are wounded
then the affected area gets healed in a
few days and we can see that the newer
skin is exactly the same as the previous
one how is all this possible it is
because of the process of cell division
this is an extremely interesting process
in which the cell makes almost an exact
copy of itself and how is it able to
make its replica all thanks to the
process of DNA replication with this the
cell is able to make a copy of itself we
know that DNA encodes everything so when
the cell is about to divide the
replication of DNA helps in conserving
the genetic information as a result the
newly formed cells carried the same
genetic information thus in order to
have similar or identical cells the
process of DNA replication and cell
division are extremely important let's
understand how this miraculous process
of DNA replication works way back in
time there were three major hypotheses
of the methods of replication put forth
one method is called the conservative
method the other is called the
dispersive method and the last one is
called the semiconservative method but
which of the methods described the
replication process correctly which
method is used by DNA to make copy
of itself let's find that out but before
we get to the answer we need to
understand the structure of a typical
DNA molecule this is how it looks this
is the backbone of the DNA molecule and
this part forms the core now let's
understand a few more interesting
concepts regarding the DNA molecule
let's begin with the backbone first can
you guess how these two strands are
arranged is there any way to
differentiate between these two yes
there is the two complimentary DNA
strands are anti-parallel and what does
this mean well in biochemistry two units
like these strands are said to be anti
parallel if they run parallel to each
other but in the opposite direction
so is there directionality that is
end-to-end alignment in the case of DNA
yes there is let's understand the
directionality in the DNA molecule
better in the next part
here is a typical structure of a DNA
molecule to understand how exactly it
replicates we need to first understand
its detailed structure to begin with
let's zoom in further we find a
structure somewhat like this these are
the representations of the nitrogenous
bases while these are that of the sugar
phosphate backbones can you state the
difference between these two backbones
it's quite simple if you notice properly
the ribose sugars in this strand a
pointing upwards while here they're
facing downwards to be precise the
oxygen atoms in these sugar molecules
are headed upwards while in these ones
they're headed downwards so doesn't it
seem that these two strands are running
in opposite directions yes they are this
is why the two strands are said to be
anti parallel is this the only reason
why we say that the two strands are
anti-parallel actually not there is a
specific way to read the directions of
the two strands and that comes not only
from the sugar molecules but also from
the phosphate groups let's understand
how we note that the phosphate groups
are attached to the sugars with the help
of phosphodiester linkages now the
interesting part is that these linkages
occur at specific positions only in
every sugar molecule the phosphate
groups are attached at the third carbon
atom and the fifth carbon atom only so
in this strand of DNA we can see that
this phosphate group is attached to this
fifth carbon atom of the sugar molecule
while this phosphate is attached to the
third also it's attached to the fifth
carbon atom of the next sugar molecule
this is how the phosphate groups link
the sugar molecules together at the
fifth and the third carbon atoms so for
a Lima this strand would look like
this a phosphate group fifth carbon atom
third carbon atom phosphate group fifth
carbon atom third carbon atom and so on
so the fifth carbon atom to which the
phosphate group is attached is called
five prime carbon and the third carbon
atom to which a free hydroxyl group is
attached is called three prime carbon to
simplify this in a DNA strand this end
is referred to as the five prime end
while this is the three prime end but
why is the term prime used here it's
simply to distinguish these carbon atoms
from the ones which are involved in
linkages with the nitrogenous bases
getting back to our explanation this is
the five prime end while this is the
three prime end the five prime end has
the phosphate group attached to it while
the three prime end has a free hydroxyl
group so the direction of the strand can
be read as five prime to three prime
from the free phosphate group to the
free hydroxyl group now can you guess
the direction of the other strand give
it a shot that's correct the direction
of this strand will be read as three
prime to five prime that's because in
this tract it begins with a 3 prime end
having the free hydroxyl group and ends
with the 5 prime end having the
phosphate group this is how the two
strands are said to be anti parallel
with respect to each other
now tell me how is this complex looking
DNA molecule replicator we had seen that
there were three theories put forth to
understand the DNA replication process
they were the conservative dispersive
and semi conservative theory but which
amongst the three is the correct one
let's understand this in the upcoming
parts
[Music]